we will now continue with the problem of
inferring the unknown bias of a certain
coin for which we have a certain try or
distribution and of which we observe the
number of heads in an independent coin
tosses we have already seen that if we
assume a uniform prior the posterior
takes this particular form which comes
from the family of beta distributions
what we want to do now is to actually
derive point estimates that is instead
of just providing the posterior we would
like to select a specific estimate for
the unknown bias let us look at the
maximum a posteriori probability
estimate how can we find it by
definition the map estimate is that
value of theta that maximizes the
posterior the value of theta at which
the posterior is largest now instead of
maximizing the posterior it is more
convenient in this example to maximize
the logarithm of the posterior and the
logarithm is K times log theta plus and
minus K times the log of 1 minus theta
to carry out the maximization over theta
we form the derivative with respect to
theta and set that derivative to 0 so
the derivative of the first term is K
over theta and the derivative of the
second term is n minus K over this
quantity 1 minus theta but because of
the minus here when we apply the chain
rule actually this plus sign here is
going to become a minus sign and now we
set this derivative to 0 we carry out
the algebra which is rather simple and
the end result that you will find is
that the estimate is equal to K over N
notice that this is lower case
J we are told the specific value of
heads that has been observed so little K
is a number and our estimate accordingly
is a number this answer makes perfect
sense a very reasonable way of
estimating the probability of heads of a
certain coin is to look at the number of
heads obtained and divided by the total
number of trials so we see that the map
estimate turns out to be a quite natural
one how about the corresponding
estimator recall the distinction that
the estimator is a random variable that
tells us what the estimate is going to
be as a function of the random variable
that is going to be observed the
estimator is uppercase K divided by
little n so it is a random variable
whose value is determined by the value
of the random variable capital K if the
random variable capital K happens to
take on this specific value little K
then our estimator this random variable
will be taking this specific value which
is the estimate and let us now compare
with an alternative way of estimating
theta
we will consider estimating theta by
forming the conditional expectation of
theta given the specific number of heads
that we have observed this is what we
call the LMS or list mean squares
estimate to calculate this conditional
expectation all that we need to do is to
form the integral of theta times the
density of theta but since it's a
conditional expectation we need to take
the conditional density of theta and the
integral ranges from 0 to 1 because this
is the range of a random variable theta
now what is this we have a formula for
the posterior density so we need to just
multiply this expression here by theta
and then integrate this term here is a
constant so it can be pulled outside the
integral and inside the integral we are
left with this term times theta which
changes the exponent of theta to k plus
1 then we have 1 minus theta to the
power n minus K D theta at this point we
need to do some calculations what is D
of n K the often K is the normalizing
constant of this PDF for this to be a
PDF and to integrate to one D of n K has
to be equal to the integral of this
expression from 0 to 1 so we need to
somehow be able to evaluate this
integral here we will be helped by the
following very nice formula this formula
tells us that the integral of such a
function of theta from 0 to 1 is equal
to this very nice and simple expression
of course this formula is only valid
when these factorials make sense so we
assume that alpha is non-negative and
beta is non-negative how is this formula
derived there's various algebraic or
calculus style derivations one
possibility is to use integration by
parts and there are also other tricks
for deriving it it turns out that there
is also a very clever probabilistic
proof of this fact but in any case we
will not derive it we will just take it
as a fact that comes to us from calculus
and now let us apply this formula D of
NK is equal to the integral of the
expression which is of this form with
alpha equal to K and beta equal to n
minus K so D of n K takes the form alpha
is K beta is n minus K and then in the
denominator we have the sum of the two
indices plus 1 so it's going to be K
plus n minus K that gives us N and then
there is a plus 1 and how about this
integral
well this integral is also of the form
that we have up here but now we have
alpha equal to k plus 1 beta is n minus
K and in the denominator we have the sum
of the indices plus 1 so when we add
these indices we get n plus 1 and then
we get another factor of 1 which gives
us an N plus 2 this looks formidable but
actually there's a lot of
simplifications this term here cancels
with that term K plus 1 factorial
divided by K factorial what is it it is
just a factor of K plus 1 and what do we
have here this term is in the
denominator of the denominator so it can
be moved up to the numerator we have n
plus 1 factorial divided by n plus 2
factorial this is just n plus 2 and this
is the final form of the answer this is
what the conditional expectation of
theta is
so now we can compare the two estimates
that we have the map estimate and the
conditional expectation estimate they
are fairly similar but not exactly the
same this means that the mean of a beta
distribution is not the same as the
point at which the distribution is
highest on the other hand if n is a very
large number this expression is going to
be approximately equal to K over N when
n is large and so in the limit of large
n the two estimators will not be very
different from each other